new faces old characters given new
programming and even a west side story
actress in the new season of westworld
all this and more as season 4 inches
ever closer to its release date watch
this before you see westworld season 4.
westworld has been a main attraction of
hbo's original programming for several
years now and after the end of game of
thrones it helped fill the network's
need for fantastical high concept thrill
rides naturally the series was renewed
for a fourth season before season three
had even ended casey bloys president of
hbo programming released a statement to
coincide with the renewal stating from
the western theme park to the
technocratic metropolis of the near
future we've thoroughly enjoyed every
twist and turn from the minds of master
storytellers jonathan nolan and elisa
joy there was a two-year break between
seasons two and three of westworld which
came out in 2018 and 2020 respectively
given that it's such a vfx heavy show it
makes sense that the westworld creative
team needs a lot of time to get
everything to look perfect in it
fortunately the long wait for season
four is nearly over as the first proper
trailer for the next chapter of
westworld revealed a premiere date of
june 26 2022
warning spoilers ahead for the season
three finale of westworld as fans of
westworld know all too well a character
dying doesn't necessarily mean an actor
is out of work considering a good
portion of the characters are androids
it's always possible for someone to die
and then have their personality uploaded
into a different unit taking that into
account audiences should expect some
familiar faces to return in westworld
season 4 including 10 dua newton as
maeve aaron paulus caleb jeffrey wright
as bernard luke hemsworth as ashley and
ed harris as the man in black the
biggest question mark of all remains the
fate of evan rachel wood's character
dolores who had her mind completely
erased during the season 3 finale in an
interview with variety co-creator
jonathan nolan confirmed that dolores is
gone however that doesn't mean evan
rachel wood is done with the show with
nolan adding i think it's important with
a show in which death can be impermanent
these are robots after all to mark the
occasion with dolores that version of
that character is gone
naturally details have been kept sparse
about any future plans for westworld
start and eway newton did however share
some intel during an appearance at the
paley center for media i have no idea
what they have planned for me i'm teamed
with tessa thompson i know hopefully we
can do some rightful damage while
speaking to variety co-creator jonathan
nolan was asked whether the show is
staying in the real world or going back
into the park for the upcoming season
and he responded by saying we love you
and we say this with the greatest
respect but there is no earthly way
we're going to answer that question
sounds like we'll just have to wait and
see what westworld has to show us in
season four
you start in the centre of the park it's
simple
safe
the further out your venture the more
intense the experience gets
westworld season 3 built the most
expansive world for our ai protagonists
yet nonetheless our characters find the
worlds they've escaped to aren't much
better than the world from which they
fled charlotte now works for and shares
a consciousness with dolores the
villainous william aka the man in black
is trapped in a mental institution for
the majority of the season and he's
haunted by visions of dolores and emily
the daughter he killed people in power
at delos and the newly introduced
organization insight continue to attempt
to play god lording over both their
human and artificial subjects season 3
of westworld carries on the themes of
classism and morality begun in the first
two seasons showing that very few humans
stand worthy of the ai character's trust
while season 3 of westworld opened new
layered avenues for plot lines to travel
down it also left many questions
unanswered for instance will caleb have
what it takes to lead the revolution for
robots and downtrodden humans will
delores somehow manage to return and
continue her relationship with caleb how
does the dolores pearl that exists
within charlotte actually work what did
bernard see when he stared into the
sublime can a robot william embrace
redemption and become a hero story
details for westworld season 4 have been
hard to come by but that hasn't stopped
fans from speculating on what's ahead
for their favorite characters westworld
has never been a show to rely on obvious
or safe storytelling and there's no
reason to think the sci-fi series will
start anytime soon myriads of loose ends
may or may not be resolved in season 4
but it's safe to assume that many
unpredictable twists
lie ahead
the westworld season 4 trailer teases a
lot of exciting possibilities but it
doesn't give much detailed insight into
what will ultimately happen or what the
world looks like after the los angeles
explosions the biggest teases in the
short dialogue-free trailer include the
man in black returning to westworld as
well as the return of evan rachel wood
we also see some intriguing shots of
maeve and caleb who both seem to be in a
decent bit of trouble given caleb's
vital role in the struggle for ai
freedom he could get captured by insight
or by some other nefarious power at some
point in the season based on the trailer
alone it looks like character
development is still at the heart of the
story which should bode well for season
4. the trailer also looks visually
stunning carrying the same flair for
vista shots and cool sci-fi locales that
westworld has always worn on its sleeve
it's been revealed that westworld season
4 will mark the return of a former cast
member james marsden marzin played the
sweet and loyal teddy in season one and
two at the atx festival westworld
co-creator lisa joy confirmed that
marzin will play a teddy look-alike who
goes on a date with evan rachel wood's
new character joy went on to confirm
that sadly dolores is dead and that
wood's new character christina has some
sort of relationship with marsden's
character of course it's tough to say
whether or not the westworld team is
really telling the whole truth it's
technically possible for teddy and
dolores to grace our screens once again
one of the most shocking twists of
westworld season 1 is the revelation
that bernard lowe is a robot bernard
spends the season creating upgrading and
working with the westworld ais which
makes it all the more heartbreaking when
bernard uncovers the truth of his
identity his memories are false
creations and he's neither human nor
fully one of the westworld ais
i understand what i'm made of
how i'm coded but i do not understand
the things that i feel
and yet bernard strives to stay centered
even while he fears he's losing his mind
in season three bernard meets his former
wife sort of and is given newfound
clarity about his own nature in an
interview with deadline wright discussed
what's to come in season four season
four is going to be more of the west
world you've come to expect and more
digging down into some issues and some
technology that is going to look
familiar to us as always speaking on
bernard's arc in particular he said
bernard is still trying to solve it all
and he is still very much a part of the
struggle the struggle goes on and
bernard is right there at the center of
it it's gonna be fun
in seasons one and two of westworld
anthony hopkins played dr robert ford
the man who started it all ford has
always been a complicated character at
times villainous and at other times the
biggest advocate for the robots of his
theme park ultimately ford's own hubris
and desire to play god overshadows his
best characteristics at the end of
season one he's shot in the head by
dolores it was thought that the season 1
finale would be the last of hopkins on
westworld yet ford spoke from beyond the
grave for much of season 2. before
season 2 began jonathan nolan spoke to
the hollywood reporter about working
with the screen in stage legend he said
it was one of the greatest privileges of
my career so far getting to work with
anthony for the first season hopkins
played forward with such nuance and
complicated humanity that it made for
extremely captivating television before
westworld he hadn't appeared on a tv
show since 1989
and seeing an actor of hopkins caliber
perform week after week captivated many
fans sadly the star didn't make any
appearances in season 3. however with
westworld we've learned to never say
never and it would be a delight to see
hopkins grace our screens again do you
know what happened to the neanderthals
banana
we hate them
season 4 of westworld looks positioned
to introduce some exciting cast
additions fresh off for academy award
win for best actress in a supporting
role in west side story ariana dubose is
set to be joining the hbo sci-fi show at
a panel at the atx tv festival series
co-creator lisa joy announced that
ariana dubose played the roommate of
evan rachel wood's new character and
that there may be some romantic tension
between the two in addition to the new
faces debuting in westworld season 4
many former and current cast members
could also find themselves playing new
characters in an interview with variety
jonathan nolan discussed the caliber of
the westworld cast and how they lend
themselves to the genre bending stories
he and joy want to tell the fun of the
show from the beginning is that one
actor can play several roles and that
the story shifts underneath them
schiff's genre shifts time nolan
continued obviously it's an astonishing
cast and giving all of them something
extremely challenging is part of the fun
of it so i think we would anticipate
seeing some or many of these spaces in
very different circumstances and very
different relationships hopefully the
dystopian world of westworld season 4
will give fans everything they've been
waiting for the new season premieres on
hbo on june 26 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite television shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you